voici un animal à la fois inclassable et
qui fascine les scientifiques le
tardigrade littéralement qui marchent
lentement moins d'un millimètre de long
translucide et une vague ressemblance
avec un ourson le voici observé au
microscope
une vidéo que cette scientifique garde
sur son téléphone
ce qui impressionne c'est leur
résistance en parler c'est un fait zéro
absolu dans certains espaces de
tardigrade peuvent résister à -273
celsius
d'autres peuvent résister à des
températures de 150 celsius donc des
chaleurs externe
on parle aussi de résistance aux
radiations aux uv aux pressions
atmosphériques
les israéliens ont donc eu l'idée d'un
an ferme et 1000 dans une capsule qui
devait se poser sur la lune à bord de
cette sonde problème la mission est un
échec
on voit le site de l'écrasement sur ces
images mais le tardigrade et du genre
coriace
quand je pense moi personnellement quand
je pense à la recherche de vie je pense
à la recherche de vie qui ressemble à
des tardigrade on n'a pas sur des
extrêmophiles c'est des formes de vie
qui peuvent survivre vraiment
environnements extrêmes la petite
colonie pourrait donc avoir survécu mais
dans un état de léthargie complète
ils résistent beaucoup dans la forme
enkystée donc le temps de grands sommets
en petites boules finalement puis ça
tombe en dormance donc ils peuvent
rester des années sous cette forme mais
est-ce qu'on ne risque pas de contaminer
la lune en envoyant ce genre d'organisme
on est exactement droit de faire ce
qu'on veut on a quand même des
règlements la qualité ni par en place
entre par la nasa
il existe le bureau de protection
planétaire de la nasa et ce bureau n'a
pas classé la lune comme une zone qui
doit être protégée à tout prix parce
qu'on l'a déjà contaminé avec
certainement télescope tempère on peut
revoir les différentes missions apollo
ont laissé des traces les apprenantes
aux cdc des matières fécales
donc on a aussi une bonne chance d'avoir
des bactéries qui ex promène sur la lune
mais pour revenir à nos tardigrade qui
inspire aussi le cinéma
ils ne vont pas muter et devenir
incontrôlable c'est une bonne forme de
vie intelligente comme on l'a défini sur
terre tout le temps de vie et comment
exceptionnel mais la taille ne pas vous
gâcher ici mathieu prost radio-canada
mourir
[Musique]